s
compliqué. Je n'ai pas plus de
policier qui va enrayer la
criminalité à Montréal.
(sirènes)
- La vague de la criminalité
et de la violence, le rappeur
Mikezup la connaît très bien.
♪ On s'entre-tue
Pour couleur de flag ♪
♪ On se fait entraîner
Dans la vague ♪
on recommence.
- Son père c'est Jean Raymond
Claude, un des membres
fondateurs du gang 67 à la fin
des années 90 dans le quartier
Saint-Michel.
♪ ♪ ♪
MIKEZUP, rappeur et fils
de Jean Raymond Claude
- Des fois, ça m'arrivait,
je lui demandais, moi : "Papa,
pourquoi t'as une arme
sur toi?" Il me disait qu'il
était un agent de sécurité.
- Et son parrain, c'est
Ducarme Joseph, un caïd du crime
organisé, assassiné en 2014.
♪ ♪ ♪
À 14 ans, il commence
à commettre des vols à étalage
et son père, en plus
en l'époque, était fièr
de son fils.
- Quand on parlait
de criminalité, il était
"involved", pour moi, c'était
une façon de me rapprocher
de mon père. Je ne le voyais
pas souvent. Je n'ai pas trouvé
d'autres moyens. J'ai fait
des affaires bien pires,
bien pires que braquer
des dépanneurs par la suite.
Et aujourd'hui, je regrette,
c'est sûr.
- En 2015, son univers bascule
quand son père est kidnappé
et présumé mort assassiné.
- Moi, j'ai deux enfants
maintenant, j'ai fait le calcul
de tout ça et je me suis dit que
ce n'est peut-être pas le chemin
approprié. Même s'il y a
des sommes importantes d'argent,
je peux faire faire moins
et voir mes enfants grandir.
Je ne vais pas répéter le même
"pattern" que mon père a fait
avec moi.
- Maintenant ce n'est plus dans
la rue que l'artiste de 25 ans
consacre son temps, mais entre
le studio d'enregistrement
et chez lui avec sa famille.
- Pour moi, il y a plein de
moments que je me sens seul,
que je me sens un peu perdu
et je vais mettre un beat
et je vais commencer à écrire
description dans ma tête.
♪ ♪ ♪
Après j'ai écrit la chanson,
j'oubliais le malaise que
j'avais juste avant d'écrire la
chanson et je suis fier d'avoir
écrit ma chanson. C'est la vie
que je vivais, c'est tout
simplement ça. Je ne vais pas
raconter une histoire qui n'est
pas la mienne.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Cette réalité, Connaisseur
Ticaso, la connaît aussi très
bien.
CONNAISEUR TOCASO, rappeur
- Ça faisait tellement partie
de ma vie, si je sortais chez
nous et que j'oubliais
mon couteau, je revenais chez
nous, je ne me sentais pas bien
sans avoir un couteau.
- Tout à 44 ans, le vétéran
rappeur affilié un gang
criminalisé d'allégeance rouge
à l'époque, revient sur scène.
La première chanson
de son nouvelle chanson
s'intitule : La rue m'appelle
encore.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une des raisons pourquoi
j'ai commencé c'est que
justement, moi, dans ce temps-
là, j'étais vraiment deep dans
le street.
- C'est quoi ta définition
d'être deep dans le street?
- Tu es impliqué dans la
violence deas gangs, fusillades,
coups de couteau. C'est
constant.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Il a perdu plusieurs de ses
amis sous les balles avec les
années. En 2007, il est condamné
à quatre ans de prison pour
un vol à main armée.
- Ça oui j'ai toujours été un
gars qui préférait la faciliter.
Dans le gang, j'ai pété du
monde, je n'ai jamais été de
même. J'ai été pris par des
circonstances, par loyauté.
- Après une altercation dans un
bar en 2015, il décide de faire
une croix sur l'univers de la
rue.
♪ ♪ ♪
Est-ce que c'est facile d'avoir
une à Montréal?
- C'est très facile.
- Mais que se passe dans les
rues de Montréal? Pour Mikezup,
un meilleur encadrement des
jeunes à l'école serait une
solution.
- On ne rencontre la vie, ces
jeunes sont dans la rue,
fontaine d'argent et ne savent
même pas faire quoi faire avec.
Il s'achète des armes. Et puis
se trouvent cool avec. Qu'est-ce
qu'on doit faire pour les
jeunes, c'est ouvrir plus de
maison des jeunes, pour donner
des activités et mettez le sport
gratuit. Je ne sais pas. Et je
ne rien à faire. Peut-être
travailleurs de vivre rue, des
gens qui vont aider ces jeunes
qui vont leur montrer le chemin
et qui ne vont pas leur montrer
une fois qui sont dans la merde,
ce sont des gens sans jeunesse.
C'est là que va avoir un travail
actuel CDD. Il a déjà mère des
points employés de l'aider. 14
- À 14 ans à présent le montrer
ce que c'est que la vie. Parce
que sinon ils vont la découvrir
par eux-mêmes et vont se casser
la gueule.
- Ça fait 17 ans que Robertson
travaille avec les jeunes de
Montréal-Nord.
- L'informatique sujet ce sont
des choses qui sont latents
depuis longtemps.
- Les conflits sont reliés à des
gangs de rue aromatique
complexe.
- Zone 43 serviteur les zones de
gang. À travers ces conflits à
des histoires personnelles
soient d'argent. Si on regarde
seulement gay de gangs on
sacrifie des gens qui sont la
mauvaise place.
- La solution se trouve peut-
être en changeant notre regard
vis-à-vis des criminels.
- En dehors de la que la
personne a commise qu'il est. Il
y a la personne et des histoires
qui amènent la et le travail de
rue c'est d'intervenir à un
moment donné de la vie de cette
personne échanger cette
histoire.
- Pour connaisseur il faut
arrêter de critiquer les jeunes.
Et les aider
- la pas de bouffe tapa de ici
c'est par choix comment tu peux
arrêter un gars qui fait ça par
choix. C'est ce qui le font
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le choix
qu'il faut aider. Mais celui qui
a 19 ans qui est dedans qu'est-
ce qu'on peut lui dire.
Demande on disait les criminels
qui ont décidé de faire la
musique.
quand son père est kidnappé
et présumé mort assassiné.
.c 6:45 en cours
(sirènes)
- La vague de la criminalité
Et justement dans l'une de ses
dernières chansons, il collabore
avec Jackboy, affilié
au Profit Boy$, un rappeur
associé à un gang autrefois
opposer à lui. Plusieurs
personnes ont salué l'audace
du geste.
- Quelques années, moi je lui en
serais peut-être-tu pour rien.
Juste parce qu'on est-elle. Tel
coin. Mais quand nous on pense
aujourd'hui on est comme on n'en
a fait du chemin, merci Dieu. Il
se faisait pas de sens.
♪ ♪ ♪